well pedestrian and cyclist crashes
continue to be a serious issue all
across Southern Nevada in fact just this
year 230 people have been hit by cars
and those working in Trauma Centers say
they want to do something to try and
change the trend Sasha Loftus joins us
live with more on the event tonight
promoting safety on our way
Denise of those crashes you mentioned
about a dozen either pedestrians or
cyclists have died on our Valley streets
in Metro's jurisdiction so far this year
those we spoke with tonight who work
here at Sunrise Hospital hope events
like this help keep everyone safer on
the road
we don't want to see people get hurt
Todd Hightower is doing what he can to
promote safety on our streets I am a
cyclist but I'm also a father a husband
a grandfather he hasn't just been hurt
while riding but he also deals with the
trauma of pedestrian and cyclist crashes
as a registered nurse at Sunrise
Hospital so I'm a trauma Survivor also
and uh so it you know it hits home here
every time he's one of many who
participated in Friday's special light
up event it really really is a major
issue on our Las Vegas streets Gene
marsala who works as the trauma
prevention coordinator at Sunrise helped
organize it after what she calls a
serious spike in people hit by cars
coming to their Trauma Center about five
seen in just the past week we have seen
a slew of pedestrians hit by cars in the
last few months she hopes this show of
solidarity will encourage those on foot
to wear bright clothing at night and
always use a crosswalk
while asking drivers to pay attention
and be aware of those around them we
just want to help promote safety here in
the community it's something Todd says
he'll also work hard to hammer home to
anyone affected we're not just an
obstruction in the road
now the event was five dollars per
person to participate today and all the
money raised went to Clark County Safe
Kids which is a local organization that
focuses on keeping children safe across
Southern Nevada reporting live tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now